nos piden evaluar la expresión cuadrada
más 10 b menos 8 cuando a es igual a 7 y
b es igual a menos 4 así que para
evaluar la expresión tenemos que
sustituir en el valor de 7 y en b el
valor de menos 4 pues nos están pidiendo
que evaluemos la expresión cuando es
igual a 7 y b es igual a menos 4 hagamos
eso cada que veamos una a en la
expresión la sustituiremos por un 7
tenemos entonces a cuadrada que sería 7
al cuadrado más
10 luego a poner el mismo color 10 por b
en vez de be tenemos que sustituir el
valor de menos 4 entonces más 10 por
menos 4 es sustituido esta vez de aquí y
todo eso menos 8 y ahora vamos a
calcular cuánto nos da esto 7 al
cuadrado es 49 luego eso le tenemos que
sumar 10 x menos 4 recuerda el orden de
las operaciones el producto va antes de
la suma entonces 10 menos 4 es menos 40
y nos queda esto 49 más menos 40 y a
todo eso le restamos menos 8 este menos
8 que tenemos aquí así que ahora tenemos
49 más menos 40 que es en realidad 49
menos 40 49 menos 40 es igual a 9 y si a
9 le restamos 8 esto nos va a dar igual
a 149 menos 49 menos 8 es igual a 1 y ya
hemos terminado hemos evaluado la
expresión cuando a es igual a 7
es igual a menos 4